They'll vary integrate,
when we want to share code between
different versions of what
are essentially the same app.
However, if we want to
build a collection of apps,
with similar capabilities,
we may instead,
want to break up some of our
functionality often to a library.
We may even simply have a collection of
utilities that we want to share across
projects, similar to
the Google lava Library.
There are two choices when creating
libraries for use with Android projects.
We can create a straight Java
project that build a .jar file, or
we can build an Android library
that creates an .aar file.
The primary difference between
the two is that an .aar or
Android archive can include
its own resources and
manifests, such as layouts or
fragments, and it uses its own R file.
The benefit of creating a Java library
is it can be used on non-Android
projects.
It's up to you to determine if a library
should be Android-specific or not.
Just keep in mind that there
are maybe future considerations, and
that Java libraries
are easier to turn into
Android libraries than
the other way around.